من جاء قبل الاخر الدجاجه ام البيضه سؤال
حير العلماء لعقود ورغم ان كثيرين اخذوا
هذا التساؤل بفكاهه الا ان علماء اجر
تجاربهم ليجيبوا اخيرا باحثون من جامعه
بريستول في المملكه المتحده وجامعتناجين
في الصين بداوا في دراسه احدى وخمسين
حفريه وتسعه وعشرين نوعا حيا يمكن تصنيفها
على انها بيوض او مواليد ووجدوا ان اسلاف
الطيور والزواحف الحديثه ربما تكون ولدت
من دون بيض اصلا فبعض هذه الانواع يمكن ان
تكون قد تطورت من اسلاف كانت حيه او انجبت
صغارا ويمكن ان تتحول الانواع في كليهما
خلال العمليه التطوريه على سبيل المثال
الطيور والتماسيح والسلاحف الحديثه تضع
بيضا عندما يكون الجنين بداخلها لا يزال
في مرحله مبكره جدا من التطور حيث يستمر
التطور خارج الام وتفقس في وقت لاحق اما
الثدييات مثل السحالي والثعابين فتحتفظ
باجنتها داخليا لفتره اطول في عمليه تعرف
باسم الاحتفاظ بالجنين الممتد البروفيسور
مايكل بانتون في جامعه بريستول حسم الجدل
اخيرا وقال ان الجواب الطبيعي للسؤال هو
انه من الواضح ان البيضه جاءت اولا لان كل
طائر يضع بيضه وذلك منذ الديناصور الطائر
الذي عاش منذ حوالي 150 مليون سنه